bello a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj allora il
gioco che sto per andare a giocare e the
words are the game che il videogame che
avevo fatto una settimana fa mi pare
siccome veramente chiesto in tantissimi
non potevano farlo ragazzi allora una
settimana fa ho fatto uscire il video
nel quale arriviamo fino a livello 15 ci
avevo messo qualcosa tipo 4 ore per
arrivare a livello 15 quindi una cosa
incredibile ma ragazzi la sapete la cosa
divertente è che io adesso li partirò da
15 dove ci eravamo fermati l'ultima
volta ma in realtà questo gioco non
salva la partita quindi ve la devo
rifare tutto si sporca
[Musica]
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj e come vi ho
detto 4 ore fa no no qualche secondo fa
riusciamo siamo su deborda bruce clay
vivo c'erano confermati appunto a
livello quindi c'e quindi ragazzi oggi
continuiamo la mia gioia la ragazza
molto 112 volte per arrivare fino qui di
nuovo
sinceramente non è così tanto per
l'ultima volta c'è un momento tipo 496
morti ed è stata una cosa pazzesca ma
non ci ho messo neanche cinque minuti
quindi porca [ __ ] sono già bello che è
incazzato e una cosa un po difficile ma
io ci riesco ok calmi calmi calmi calze
modo non c'è un attimo di pausa che
spiazzo giornata dalla femmina
l'ho vista mi sono visto la morte in
faccia ma io sono un [ __ ] di webcam
mentre già questo gioco che mi fa
effetto io vi giuro
vi giuro che no no a ragazzi per
arrivare di nuovo al 15 o non ve lo dico
il casino che ho fatto non ve lo voglio
dire
ma ci ho messo dei secoli per arrivare
fin qui ok quindi vediamo riuscire ad
andare avanti
mi sono rotto i [ __ ] sono cinque
minuti che già normalmente sono quattro
ore e 5 minuti che gioco non esattamente
cinque minuti ma non importa quindi sono
sì sì ok ok
credetemi se vi dico che questo è il
gioco
credetemi se vicino credetemi seguito
credetemi se vi dico che questo è il 4 a
yara io vorrei capire come cazzo fatto
l'ultima volta a fare gli ultimi livelli
in 4 secondi
se questo ci sto mettendo due anni non è
possibile sì sì su cup luca ok ok ok ok
madonna madonna 6 l'ultimo l'ultima ti
prego ci sa fare l'ultimo pezzo ma vi
rendete conto una cosa inguardabile
cioè non si può fare la cosa si vabbè
dai ciao ok ok ok un cazzo e schivate
alla madonna
sì sì ma ti prego ti prego accendere un
cero adotterò ma minucciano qualcosa
sì sì sì sì sì chi sei cazzo lo zio e lo
zio
oddio ma si passi ma si passa in mezzo
andranno a cagare
no non è una cagata sì 22 no per 3 3 ma
[ __ ] ragazzi in possesso 200 284
morti
john non quanto avevo fatto il primo
livello 192 costo facendo duecento no
tav ha fatto 100 morti sono in questo mi
sembra formale st corsa per l'europa
hanno allora aspettate per gli altri ci
si guarda lo riguardano come si di
estrema donna ma dopo il chievo cazzo
sto facendo
oddio oggi tutto questo è un momento che
passerà alla storia
segnatevi data e ora adesso
[Musica]
dai cazzo in totale ho fatto quattro 144
morti e siamo al secondo livello di oggi
avete capito la gravità della situazione
che cos'è sto schifo come faccia a
passarmi 4 aiuto ed è giusto ok ok ok
chiaro ho capito state fermi madonna
madonna tutto lui tutto madonna mia non
ci moschetta soprattutto lui tutto lui
cosa faccio
guardalo ci voglio credere
non ci voglio credere no no chi chiama
hai creato alla fine è stato un caso
assurdo aggiunge farò mai più
già già porca [ __ ] quando capisci che
sei [ __ ] è veramente tragico regali
devo riuscire allora fermi un attimo ce
la posso fare prima ce l'ho fatta e
stato lo so che è stato un caso su un
milione però ci voglia di provare ce la
posso fare io sono stupido
oddio rega allora questa è quella buona
mi sento lo sento me lo sento
me lo sento sì sì no no xvi addio addio
santo questa merda mi sembra di essere
in un alveare che cazzo è sta merda
ragazzi grazie
ma cos'è ma siamo scherma posso mai
prendere queste cose io ho ragazzi
proviamoci comunque abbiamo inaugurato
quasi le chic perfetto 500 morti
fantastico e meraviglioso ragazzi voglio
dedicare questo fantastico traguardo a
tutti quanti voi che mi avete
consigliato questo bellissimo gioco sono
veramente grato di avere degli iscritti
già mismi pensa non mi vogliono così
tanto
bene grazie grazie mille dai dai sì sì
il primo ha fatto il primo ne mancano 25
ma non importa ragazze aspettate ma
forse sono più di 25 st nonna quarantina
ma non importa ragazze ci posso fare no
non ce la posso fare
russo come sono non so come sono
arrivato qui non lo voglio sapere
non ci puoi pensare di merda fatto di
merda di concentrazione concentrazione
non ci credo non ci posso credere
ragazzi non ci posso credere è stato
pazzesco
e stato questo lo faccio tutto di fila
come non detto lunga ragazzi non
potrebbe entrare semplicemente qualcuno
con un mitra e fare fuori tutte ste
cazzo di palline inutili no perché
sarebbe veramente utile secondo messo
gioco ha veramente mietuto più vittime
che la peste nera perché è assurdo è una
cosa pazzesca per il carso di livello
senza sclerare non credo proprio
[Musica]
ragazzi non mi fate spiegare come ho
fatto perché non lo saprei spiegare
effettivamente non lo so ma va bene così
ennesimo a livello stati pensa per
diventare più difficili adesso perfetto
perché finora è stata una grandissima
passeggiata porca [ __ ] ragazzi è
stata una cosa appare cose perché sono
diventate viola le palline che cazzo mi
rappresentano stai palline viola c'è una
cosa che mi periferico ok ok ok
madonna madonna madonna tutto lui ho
dimenticato una pallina per [ __ ]
aspettati un grano dimenticata una
regale dovrei come cazzola prendo
crescini ciao ragazzi è stato un grande
onore conoscervi essere arrivato fin qui
per me è un traguardo che vale la mia
stessa vita dalla morte
sono vivo io sono io sono vivo basta
credere in se stessi sì sì devo fare una
roba troppo strana strada un attimo si è
un grande onore ricevere questo premio e
[ __ ] che gli è stato pazzesco è
stato livello 21 non ci posso che allora
non so se riesco a farlo regalo io ve lo
dico ci ho provato
ve lo dico già in anticipo ci ho provato
a rischio di sci un cazzo come faccio si
ok la prima lo zio
oddio oddio no zucca zucca di nuovo su
kawar dolori madonna madonna regalatemi
fair inferi non ci posso credere
sono un [ __ ] perché i ragazzi si
come sta succedendo un evento abbastanza
strano che il sto riuscendo a fare una
cosa che non pensavo di riuscirci vado
vado da adesso adesso vado vi giuro un
attimo perché ora un attimo ancora ok
[Musica]
mortacci tua
queste ragazze ho capito devo prendere
prima quello là in fondo devo andare
tutto spirito regala perché sennò non
torno più indietro un problema devo
andare allora vai vai vai vai vai un po
ok ce la posso farci un personaggio così
fai e cominciamo soro
[Musica]
sì sì oddio come caccia fatta non
beccarmi non ha beccato mica se riesco
guarda lo guardi io mio real ci stiamo
avvicinando al traguardo nella storia è
stata sua nostri tanti ragazzi voglio
ringraziare tutta la mia famiglia
tutti quelli che mi stanno vicino
[Musica]
dai che sto ridendo ancora prima di
vincere perchè magari poi perdono in
media invece no
invece no invece no invece no
perfetto ragazzi sta iniziando ad
approcciare questo livello in tutta la
sua bellezza sono tanto che non è poi
così semplice
una donna sarò sono morto già una
trentina di volte da sto punto di cui
faccio a passare di qua ti qui a cio che
gia fatta per la prima volta ce l'ho
fatta adesso vado al caso caso trovai a
pavè regalo ed è troppo difficile questo
ci metterei dei secoli ci metterò dei
secoli perché lo farò ma dio mia se lo
farò concludo che l'episodio per oggi
perché ho fatto delle corse che non
pensavo siccome ragazzi ci metterà nei
secoli ha ri arrivare fino a questo
punto qui c'è cercherò di farlo appena
riesco perché non è proprio una cosa da
cinque minuti evidentemente siccome non
so neanche se il giorno e notte fuori
magari adesso ho finito vado a vedere ai
ragazzi finisco che l'episodio come al
solito selvi dove è piaciuto lasciato
argomento mi piace anche a pagliari
facebook e come non di video tratte
nella descrizione e serre se la crisi
discutere ci vediamo al prossimo vito
era ragazzi